- [Narrator] How has the position
of Speaker of the House changed over time?
- The position of Speaker of the House
has changed a lot over time
and it has had powerful early advocates,
Henry Clay, an early Speaker of the House
who had three different
terms as Speaker of the House
used the position to shepherd all kinds of
legislation to improve America.
He also played a crucial
role in John Quincy Adam's
becoming President because
the election was thrown
into the House.
He was quite powerful.
Then the job kind of got less powerful.
There were periods during the Civil War
where there wasn't a Speaker of the House
for long periods because
there was so much contention
in the Congress they couldn't
pick a Speaker of the House.
The modern Speaker of the House has become
increasingly powerful really growing with
the growth of the federal government
around let's say the second World War.
Various different Speakers
gaining more power
and in the recent incarnation
the Speaker is particularly powerful
in two different ways.
One is shepherding a
President's legislation
if the Speaker is from the same party
and the other is in opposition.
They become essentially the opposition
speaking against a President
of an opposite party.
So people like that would be Nancy Pelosi
now with President Trump
or John Boehner with President Obama
or Tip O'Neill with President Reagan.
So they are the key person in doing combat
with whoever's in the White House
if they're from the opposite party.